what has Melissa Rous done to convince
her kids she's part of the judicial
system her career went in a slightly
different direction after the Big Bang
Theory ended Melissa Rous bid her
character Dr bernardet Rosen Kowski
walowitz goodbye on The Big Bang Theory
more than four years ago with her
adorable facade and Cutthroat actions
bernardet is one of the most intriguing
Big Bang Theory characters not only is
the mother of two a brilliant scientist
but she also managed something
incredible getting her h usband Simon
helberg's Howard walowitz to suppress
his proclivity for being sleazy around
women Rous also put on a cartoon-like
voice when portraying bernardet for this
reason it should come as no surprise
that she has been a successful voice
actor following the Big Bang Theory take
a look at her filmography and you'll see
that the actor brought animated
characters to life for the kid-friendly
shows firebuds and the chicken Squad in
addition when she is not in a recording
studio Rous puts on her executive
producer hat for the night court reboot
she also has been showing off her comedy
skills as the show's protagonist judge
Abracadabra Abby Stone Rous discussed
the Night Court reboot in a February
2023 interview on the Jennifer Hudson
show the New Jersey native shared that
she believes those unfamiliar with the
comedy's source material would like the
new show just as much as hardcore fans
she hinted that her character inherited
her father's inability to hide his
Whimsy even while wearing his judge robe
the actor shared what I love about it is
that people who loved the original
Incarnation there's so much for them
that they will remember and Nostalgia
and just all these little Easter eggs
that they will remember from the
original and then for people who don't
have any prior knowledge of it they can
come into it with fresh eyes and they
don't need to have you know that
familiarity with it either well R
clearly takes pride in her work it seems
that her children might not be quite as
enthusiastic about her job even though
her kids Brooks and sad may have enjoyed
a few episodes of firebuds and the
chicken Squad it's unlikely they are
that aware their mother is an actor on
the animated shows while speaking to
Hudson The Big Bang Theory star
explained that her son and daughter are
under the impression that she actually
works in a court of law is it wrong I
haven't corrected them no you could keep
it in your back pocket I they've seen
the posters for it they're like Mom's a
judge I'm like yes I am during a
February 2023 appearance on The View
Rous shared that there have been some
tricky aspects about appearing in night
court she noted that some Big Bang
Theory viewers may find watching the
2023 sitcom jarring because she did not
change her natural voice the actor joked
I don't tend to read a lot of Instagram
comments but I did notice that people
were concerned that I wasn't using the
same voice that I use for bernardet on
Big Bang the reaction is a little bit
like when you are transitioning from
silent movies into Takis like people are
horrified that I'm not talking like that
however Rous does not seem to mind being
associated with her Big Bang Theory
character the actor helped contribute to
the 2022 book The Big Bang Theory the
definitive inside story of the Epic hit
series during an October 2022 interview
with the book's author Jessica radoff
Rous shared that she missed the CBS
comedy for several reasons she noted
that she longed for the days that she
could regularly interact with the big
bang theory cast and crew but it's not
just her co-workers she missed she
apparently was also very fond of the
omelet bar that was set up for the show
Stars once a week either way it seems
she has as much love for her time on the
show as her fans
do oh